Moments before the attack, the mayor of Gdansk
praising the fundraising effort for children
in need.
As Pavel Adamowicz looked out at thousands
of people, a man lunged at him with a knife.
The attacker then remained on stage, shouting
that he blamed the mayor's former party for
wrongfully imprisoning him, before he was
tackled to the ground.
He was holding a knife in his right hand and
yelled that he'd spent five years in jail
because of the mayor's old party.
He said his name, that he'd been in prison
and was tortured.
We don't know how he managed to get on the
stage.
Police have arrested the suspect, who they
said was a 27-year-old with a record of violent
crime.
Our priority is finding out how the perpetrator
could get so close to the Mayor.
We know he used a pass that said 'press' on
it.
Adamovitch was rushed to hospital in a critical
condition, with wounds to the heart and abdomen,
and underwent hours of surgery.
Poland has been left in shock by the attack
on this popular politician.